it is great to be back at the London
screen Academy to celebrate the global
Powerhouse that is our film and
television industry from Star Wars to
Game of Thrones 007 to top gun Maverick
You Name It We Make it and in fact right
here is where we're training up the next
generation of bafta winners The
Producers set designers Vision effect
Specialists who are going to ensure that
the UK remains one of the most creative
countries in the whole world
now the reason I've come here to talk
about maths is not just because I like
maths but because what I'm setting out
today is a fundamental part of how we
need to change our country for the
future
now one of my five priorities is
economic growth
and if we're going to grow our economy
not just over the next two years but the
next 20 we simply cannot allow poor
numeracy to cost our economy tens of
billions a year or to leave people twice
as likely to be unemployed as those with
competent numeracy
so we have to fundamentally change our
education system so it gives our young
people the knowledge and skills they
need and that our businesses need to
compete with the best in the world
and there's no better example of that
than in our creative Industries because
what's the biggest skill shortage
holding our film industry back well as
you heard from Jillian it's a shortage
of technical skills
and so what of the London screen Academy
put on the curriculum for their 16 to 19
year olds Mass why because you can't
make movies without maths you can't make
visual effects without vectors and
matrices you can't design a set without
some geometry you can't run a Film
Production Company without being
financially literate
and that's not just true of our creative
Industries
it's true of so many of our Industries
in healthcare
maths allows you to calculate dosages in
retail data skills allow you to analyze
sales and calculate discounts and the
same is true in all our daily lives from
managing household budgets to
understanding mobile phone contracts or
mortgages
now we also know the baths the benefit
of Maths for employability and earnings
even just basic numeracy skills can
increase your earnings by around 1 600
pounds a year
so put simply without a solid foundation
in maths our children risk being left
behind shot out of careers they aspire
to and the lives that they want to lead
now in the last decade or so we've gone
up 10 places in the international league
tables and mass has become the most
popular of all a levels
but it's still the case
that the UK is one of the least numerous
countries in the developed World more
than 8 million adults have numeracy
skills below those expected of a
nine-year-old
and around a third of our young people
don't pass math GCSE
now it's not that we're not just good
enough at Mass there's a cultural issue
here too
I'll be honest when my two young
daughters first heard me talk about them
doing more maths they weren't too
excited
and that's just it we make jokes about
not being able to do maths it's socially
acceptable we say things like oh man
maths I can't do that it's not for me
and everyone laughs but we'd never make
a joke like that about not being able to
read
so we've got to change this anti-math
mindset we've got to start prizing
numeracy for what it is a key skill
every bit as essential as reading
so my campaign to transform our national
approach to maths is not some nice to
have
it's about changing how we value maths
in our country and changing the way our
education system works to deliver it so
that all our children get these vital
skills for life
now parents and teachers listening to
this will want to know what that means
for our children today so let me tell
you
we're in the process of making maths
more accessible building our children's
confidence so that they don't fear maths
we're creating more sector specific
content that can excite young people
about the relevance of mass for the
careers that they aspire to
to help teachers bring math to life in
the classroom from building sets for
school plays to calculating the angles
of free kicks or the speed of a Formula
One card
we're extending our math hubs unique
Partnerships of expert schools that
support math teaching and we're
strengthening maths in primary schools
including with a new fully funded
professional qualification for those
that are teaching it
but we also need to address a very
specific problem that's causing us to
fall behind the rest of the world
we're one of the few developed countries
where young people don't routinely study
some form of maths up to the age of 18.
they do it in Australia Canada France
Germany Finland Japan Norway and America
why should we accept any less for our
children of course we shouldn't
that's why I set out in January that
we're going to change the way our system
works so that everyone in our country
will study some form of maths all the
way to 80.
but let me be absolutely clear I am not
saying that the answer is a level math
for everyone
but we do need to work out the maths our
young people should study
so we're going to look at what 16 to 18
year olds around the world are learning
and we're going to listen to employers
and ask them what they say the math
skills are that they need
and that's why today I'm appointing a
new expert group
who will help us identify the core maths
content that our 16 to 18 year olds need
and whether we need a new specific
qualification to support that
but to repeat that will not be a level
Maths for all
and let me also be clear
that we're not going to deliver this
change overnight we're going to need to
recruit and train the Math teachers
we're going to work out how to harness
technology that we need to support them
and we'll need to make sure that this
math is additional to other subjects not
instead of them
just as here at the London screen
Academy
they don't teach maths instead of the
Arts they teach both
because they are complementary not
contradictory
so it will take time to implement this
change but we are taking the first step
today by identifying the math content
that will give hour 16 to 18 year olds
the skills they need to get on in life
and when we have that then we'll come
back with a detailed plan to deliver it
I'll just finish on a personal note
every opportunity that I've had in life
began with the education that I was so
fortunate to receive
and mass was a critical part of that now
I knew it was important then and when I
look at how the world is changing it's
only going to be more important for my
children and yours
so I won't sit back and allow this
cultural sense that it's okay to be bad
at maths to put our children at a
disadvantage we've got to change this
we've got to Value math and what it can
do for our children's futures
giving our children a world-class
education is the single most important
thing we can do it's the closest thing
we have to a silver bullet the best
Economic Policy the best social policy
the best moral policy and that's why I'm
proud that it's our policy and I will
never stop striving to achieve it
thank you
right thanks very much now we've got
time for a good bunch of questions so
before we get to the media I was going
to see now do you want to do you guys
have any questions to start with and
then we'll see who else has some I've
got a question
um you mentioned that a-level math isn't
for everyone
um so we see like more kind of diversity
in the different types of maths courses
that we could potentially do Post 16.
brilliant that is
and I think when I first went
uh everyone was very panicked that it
meant a-level Maths for everybody and
that's why I wanted to be crystal clear
that it's not now it's great though that
it's recognized you know more and more
people are taking a level maths and as
Jillian will remind us it is now the
most popular a level right so it's a
sign of progress but what we're
announcing today is a new expert group
of people drawn from Academia from
business from all sorts of walks of life
from education and and they're going to
help us figure out exactly what that
content should be and one way we're
going to look at that is by talking to
businesses and say in all these
different Industries what are the type
of math skills that you value and that
you need and we're going to look around
the world because as I pointed out we're
literally one of the very few developed
countries where we don't have our
children study Maps up to 18. so we're
going to look around at all those
countries I mentioned and say well what
are all their students studying between
16 and 18 because that should give us a
rough sense of of what you need and
we'll put those two things together and
then we'll say aha this is it and it
won't be a level math it will be
something different and then we'll
figure out how to deliver that so you're
exactly right so hopefully that sounds
good and gives you some reassurance as
well right who's next anyone else
all good
no no others from you anyway anyone else
have some questions before we get over
to the media
okay gosh it's very quiet anyway
actually I've brought up do you have any
questions on things that are not related
to maths I'm also fine for those
all fine right okay well it's a little
turn to the media for some questions so
we start with the BBC
thank you prime minister Chris Mason BBC
News you talked today about an
aspiration but with very little detail
and yet the context is one where for
many pupils and parents there's no
further disruption to their education
with strikes coming up as well as the
prospect of strikes going on for months
and months ahead in the NHS shouldn't
the stripes and sorting them out quickly
be your priority
all right thanks Chris so lots in there
it's the first thing to say is let's
talk about what's going on in schools
and there'll be some teachers here and
the first thing I want to say and
Jillian would would Echo this is that I
I think our teachers do an incredible
job that you've probably heard from what
I said earlier I think delivering a
world-class education system is about
the most important thing that we can do
for our children's Futures and for our
country and that starts with having the
best teachers or the research tells you
that our own experience as parents tells
you that the most transformative thing
for a child's education is the quality
of the teaching and that's why it's
right that we respect we Revere and we
support our teachers and I'm so grateful
to them for the incredible job they do
and that's why we worked really hard to
find a way to come to what I thought was
a reasonable and fair settlement on pay
and it represented about an eight
percent increase for most teachers
around a 13 increase for new teachers
taking their starting salary up to 30
000 pounds
the course of the next year which is
something that we've committed to do a
couple of years ago and I'm pleased that
we're able to deliver that but it's not
also just about the money one of the
things that we hear a lot from teachers
is about workload and finding ways to
reduce that so what we've actually
worked out with the unions and Julian
did a great job is identifying ways to
reduce the workload by about five hours
a week and so put together we thought
that that was a reasonable and fair
package in the circumstances and so
obviously I'm disappointed and I said I
don't want our kids education to be
disrupted I think no one wants to see
that our door is always open and we you
know we continue to hope that we can
find a way through but as I say that
that was that's the situation on that
and we are able to focus on that but
it's also right that we look to the
Future it's also right that we think
about our kids and how we can make sure
that they can fulfill all the
opportunities ahead of them live the
lives that we want them to live make
sure they can enter every career compete
with everyone around the world go about
their daily lives just getting their
mortgage figuring out the discounts all
the things I talked about that's
fundamental to building a strong country
and a strong society and that's right
that we we put in there the plans for
that I admit as I said not going to
happen overnight right this is a big
long-term reform but we're taking the
first step today and as
um brilliant first question it was about
it's about figuring out what's the
content and once we've got the content
right then I can come back and then talk
to you about what does that mean for the
new teachers how we're going to teach
the course and how we're going to roll
it out but it's a first step on that
Journey look on on the NHS
look I think let's start with the
Positive news right of slightly lost I
think the positive news is that the
union with the largest number of NHS
workers Unison actually voted to accept
and support the New Deal that we put
forward right and I think people might
have not quite got that over some of the
coverage you know NHS workers are
represented by about half a dozen
different unions and the largest one of
those as I said voted to accept the deal
um and not just by little bit
overwhelmingly almost three to one I
think from the numbers that I uh that I
saw and I think that's a good very
positive step and I'm really grateful uh
to them for that and more generally
grateful to all our fantastic NHS
workers for the job that they do
particularly coming out of the pandemic
as we know it's been challenging and
again similar to what I was saying on
schools that's why we worked really hard
to put in place what we thought was a
reasonable Fair responsible pay
settlement and I'm actually pleased
um this is that those union leaders
recommended that deal to their members
and the RCN leadership actually said
that the government had made progress in
the talks improved the offer and they
went and recommended that offer to their
to their members and you can see that I
think in the in the narrow nature of the
vote kind of I was 54-46 so it was a
very narrow vote
um rejecting the pay offer and when you
look at the turnout it's a you know
minority of members of that Union who
are voting to strike and I think you
know voting the strike with no
derogations given given the closeness of
the vote is obviously disappointing and
you know I think everyone will be
concerned about the impact on patient
care
um but as I said you know our door was
always open to have talks and there are
other unions who are currently in the
process of balloting their members and
you know hopefully they can see that the
offer that we put forward is a
reasonable one that recognizes their
hard work and the contribution they make
and also recognizes that we have to do
these things in a way that's affordable
for taxpayers but also gets inflation
down right right it's the first one of
my priorities it's a half inflation
that's because all of you in this room
everyone watching is impacted by the
cost of living and what they're seeing
with their bills I think we all share a
desire to ease that burden and that
means being disciplined as well so we
can get inflation down ease the burden
on bills and that's what we're going to
do
right uh can I turn to Sky next
foreign
thank you prime minister Beth Rigby from
Sky News um prime minister you talked
about your excellent independent
education in the way in which that built
your maths abilities you also said a
third of kids fail maths that Jesus seen
you said that this was a cultural issue
but isn't it a provision issue because
nearly half of maths teachers around
Secondary School schools here in
Islington or in Hackney next door they
don't have a specialized maths teacher
at State School teaching them maths not
16 to 18 but up to GCSE so I put it to
you for parents listening to this today
wouldn't it be better if as prime
minister you actually gave a commitment
that kids would be given the tools in
state schools to pass maths GCSE and
make a commitment to that and fix the
basics before you talk about the next
steps because for many parents they
can't even get a good State School maths
teacher for their secondary school kids
you know what the good news is we're
doing both right and that's and that's
positive of course we can't wait till
16. we've got to make sure that we not
only change the culture of how we
approach math as a society and that's
something that's pervasive and uh and
will take time
um but we're starting actually a primary
school and I highlighted a couple of the
great things that Nick and Jillian uh
are doing one of them is something
called math hubs and we now have 40 of
these hubs which are specialist schools
that help train other schools and how to
teach maths at primary and they work
actually we know the evidence tells us
they work all the research and tells us
that they work and we're rolling that
out so actually over the course of this
Parliament we'll get to around I think
Nick will correct me about three
quarters of all primary schools and so
that's a great Innovation
um we I talked about the curriculum
changes we're making just to help make
the content more engaging and I remember
talking to a fantastic math teacher you
know who is using I think freak as I've
mentioned in my speech actually talking
about football and free kicks to teach
time and distance and angles and it's
things like that that actually really
help and but also you talk about
teachers at Primary School we're rolling
out a brand new mpq for Math teachers
and it's going to be fully funded so no
cost to the teachers and that will
really help it'll be voluntary but it'll
be very supportive of the teachers who
are doing exactly the job that you
mentioned Beth which is so important and
they deserve our support and those are
some of the building blocks that we put
in place to do that and you look you
know I'd make the point that we have
made programs we've moved up 10 points
in the international rankings but we
need to do more
um and you know I think if you look at
what Nick did previously in phonics in
particular you know our track record on
this stuff is great right you know in
2012 nickel correct me I think less than
60 of our six-year-olds were had the
proficient standard in reading but
because we were formed and put a lot of
folks and attention to it that now is
well over 80 percent and increasing so
look we know we can do this when we
focus on it properly and we're going to
bring that same discipline and focus to
Matt and you're right it will start a
primary school we're already getting on
with that and and we'll also look at the
long-term reforms for post 16. so just
so you think previous conservative
governments dropped the ball on maths
when a third of kids are fail in
Massachusetts if you look at it this has
been a long-term pervasive issue uh as I
said we've actually just made progress
over the last decade or so we've moved
up 10 points in the international
rankings for Mass we're rolling out
maths Hobbs we're rolling out the new
mpq and so and we're actually I think
Nick will correctly but multiplication
tables for the first time we just did in
this last year actually so we have made
lots of progress and look if you look at
what's going on reading in particular
it's been extraordinary but we're gonna
we're gonna also shift uh and make sure
that we emphasize Mass more than we've
done in the past but that cultural thing
has been as I said it's been pervasive
for a long time in our country and that
won't change overnight but all of us can
play a part in in helping to change it
over time
um great we go to ITV next
thank you rumbly weeks ITV News prime
minister when children's education is
being disrupted because of the strikes
When people's operations are being
canceled their care compromised because
of strikes isn't the most pressing maths
problem at the moment what formula
you're going to come up with for ending
them and do you acknowledge there is
going to have to be more money put on
the table
not to repeat too much what I said
before but there has been more money put
on the table significant more money and
in fact that was recognized by the the
unions and particularly by the
leadership of the nurses unit they are
at RCN at the time that we announced the
agreement and I think it's important for
people to recognize that right the union
leaders
actually supported the pay deal they
recognized that it was a big step
forward from where we were that it did
put new money on the table that it was
progress and that's why they recommended
it to their members and as I said the
largest Union for NHS workers has
accepted the the deal all their members
have overwhelmingly and we still have
other unions that are left to vote so I
think we should let that process play
out and you know as I said people will
hopefully go over the numbers and see
that it does represent you know a good
and fair settlement in the circumstances
and it's also not just about pay as I
said for teachers you know we're keen to
see where we can work with them to
reduce the workload and make progress
but look you know we remain committed to
finding way through these things I think
people can see actually over the past
month or two that we can sit down and
have reasonable and constructive
conversations and negotiations and we'll
continue to take that attitude going
forward
um next time's radio
good morning prime minister Lucy Fisher
from times radio
you've said this morning that it will
take time to implement the maths to 18
policy can you give any rough time scale
of when you'd like to see that start and
secondly I wanted to ask you about NHS
waiting lists which you've vowed to
bring down and to reduce the time that
patients are waiting for treatment
last week official NHS England figures
showed waiting lists have gone up not
down reaching a new record high of 7.22
million people waiting for routine
Hospital operations Health strikes are
predicted only to exacerbate the back
law so are you losing hope that you can
successfully cut NHS waiting lists
thanks Lucy on the first one about the
timing for this so we're expecting the
group to come back to us about July um
with a kind of sense of what's the
curriculum that we should be looking at
for 16 to 18 and then once we have that
then I think the next you know you'd
expect us later in the year to be able
to then come back and say well this is
how we will implement it over what time
scale and we want to get it right but
that's a rough time scale on the next
steps of this but look you can't rush
something like this it's a big reform
and it's important that we get it right
and that's why first we need to figure
out what it is that we need the
curriculum to be and once we know that
and we can think about what does that
mean for teachers how can we use
technology and what's the pace of which
this can be rolled out and on um waiting
list yes it's really important to me
that we cut NHS waiting list that's why
it's there as one of my five priorities
now I I set out a few ways that that was
going to happen how we were going to
measure ourselves you know last year we
hit the first of those targets which was
to practically eliminate the number of
people waiting at two years for
treatment which is obviously
unacceptable so that was done and
accomplished it's spring this year I
said that we would practically eliminate
those waiting a year and a half for
their treatment and yeah I said we were
on track to do that the industrial
action obviously makes that more
challenging but we're pushing hard to
meet that Target and then what I said is
that by Spring of next year we would aim
to virtually eliminate the one-year
waiters but also at that point have the
overall waiting list falling right so
that's the kind of time scale that I set
out for those and I said the next one is
you know people waiting a year and a
half making sure that we eliminate
practically this spring and we're
working really hard to do that I'm
really grateful to everyone in the NHS
who has been working exceptionally hard
to focus on that and we're going to do
that in a range of different ways I I do
remain hopeful right of course
industrial action makes uh makes these
things more challenging
um but which we're making sure that all
the extra money that we've put in the
NHS and remember it is billions and
billions of bounds extra that we've put
in the NHS and social care over the next
couple of years is spent really well on
driving down the waiting list so whether
that's new community diagnostic Centers
easy One-Stop shops to get all the
Diagnostics you need whether it's new
elective surgical hubs where we
concentrate specialty elective activity
whether it's we work with those those
trusts that are not doing as well as
others and learn and pass our best
practice around there's lots of
different initiatives that we've got
which are going to help us bring those
waiting lists down and something that
I'm focused on and I'm going to continue
to to make sure we deliver but look of
course industrial action makes that more
challenging but we're going to keep
going at it because it's important to
the country next the Sun
thank you jackass from the Sun
um prime minister at the age of 16 uh
you can join the Army but under your
plans you won't be able to decide
whether to drop maths
um isn't forcing people to study a
subject they loathe just chucking good
money away and secondly if I may um do
you support changing the name of the
Brecken beacons or is it just virtue
signaling so on look
it's actually literally coming at the
wrong the wrong way so you ask yourself
why is it that virtually every other
developed country in the world thinks
that it's the right thing for their
children to be studying some form of
maths up to 18. right and if you look at
it why is it that we're not doing as
well as I think we all want to do when
it comes to numeracy in in our country
today and then you've got to ask
yourself is that right and I don't think
anyone could justify that right right
you know and it's not it's not it's not
good for anybody and it's actually
disproportionately not good for those
who are more disadvantaged because it's
more likely for them to not have a job
it's more likely that they're missing
out on you know 1 600 pounds a year of
extra earnings uh I don't want that I
don't think you want that I don't think
anyone wants to see that right so it's I
think it's right that we try and see if
we can address that and that's what
we're going to do and we're going to do
it carefully and we're going to make
sure that we get the curriculum right
and as I said it's not about forcing
everyone to do maths a level right but
it's about making sure that they study
the right form of maths and it's about
changing the culture and that's
incredibly important and I are actually
is reflective when I first announced
this in January I saw some of the
reaction to it and I thought that
actually spoke to this kind of anti-max
mindset that we've got to challenge a
little bit right and I'm just you know
this is not about if setting up this
false contest between well do you do
creative subjects or you do maths as you
guys do brilliantly here you do both
right and most careers in most
Industries are going to require both and
you can't be socially acceptable or
culturally acceptable for us not to
Value maths in the way that we currently
do and you know I think that's if you've
got five minutes I you know urge
everyone to spend five minutes this
evening on the national enumeracy
website and there's charity who does you
know really excellent work in this area
that I came across a little while ago
when I was Chancellor and there's
there's some really powerful research
case studies examples of the challenges
we face around changing this culture
around mass and and I think it's
actually you know had an impact on me
and just when I was out and about and I
think if you spend five minutes on that
website and read some of the things
about that you'll see why this is so
important and while we all need to work
together to try and bring about and
bring about this change and then lastly
if I go to the telegraph
Telegraph
sorry
on the Brecken beacons
God I haven't you know I haven't seen it
so I've kept back to you on it right so
I missed that sorry and all my prep for
this
um Telegraph
thanks prime minister Dominic Penner on
The Daily Telegraph
um
the consensus across the sector has been
broadly supportive but people are saying
that more specialist teachers and more
funding is needed how much more funding
are you prepared to put into these
reforms and would that be new money or
existing money from elsewhere and what
you actually plan to do to win the
argumentary on maps often just extend it
to 18 how do you plan what arguments
would you make to change that anti-mass
mindset yeah you know quite great a
great couple to finish finish on Dominic
so thank you so firstly on teachers yes
look we we need we need already and we
will need more Math teachers and we know
that and as I was doing all the work for
this over the past few months with Nick
and Jillian I was kind of going over we
actually have an enormous amount of
support in place for stem graduates to
become Math teachers another stem
teachers actually and that's sort of
worth recapping it because I'm not sure
everyone is aware and so now if you if
you're coming for one of those
backgrounds you can get a tax-free
bursary worth up to 27 000 pounds
to take your teacher training right so
that's that's I think most people will
see that that's the significant sum to
kind of incentivize you to come from
those backgrounds tax-free uh to go and
do teacher training in these subjects
and then but we don't stop there we
don't stop there in these particular
subjects like maths and other some stem
subjects and in particular parts of the
country where there are shortages or we
really want to add extra help if you go
and work in those subjects or in those
areas you can get extra payments worth
around five thousand pounds a year
tax-free for around five years and that
all comes on top of your starting salary
which is going up to 30 000 pounds and
so those are some of the things that
we've got in place because you're right
we need to attract more people into
these stem areas and those are some of
the provisions that we've put in place I
said 27 000 pounds tax reversary when
you're training to become a teacher and
then on top of that payments worth up to
five thousand pounds a year for the
first few years because all the evidence
tells us it's those early years that are
so important to keeping and keeping
teachers in the profession and that's
why we focus on raising the starting
salary it's why we focus these extra
payments on those early career teachers
and look it is making a difference and
things are improving but we've got you
know we've got work to do there and
that's why as I said when we come back
with a more detailed implementation plan
for this we'll be able to look at what
does that mean for future maths needs
but I also think it's not just about
money it's as we change the culture and
more people study maths you know we've
got a virtuous circle actually because
there'll be a bigger pool of people
um to be able to draw from to teach
these uh teach these subjects um and uh
your your same question You'll Think of
questions about how do we change the
culture right which is
really important I said everyone should
spend five minutes on the national
numeracy website when they get home
today
um but I think I think it's about
you know it's about first of all with
content in primary schools and that is
about giving teachers the confidence to
teach you and that's why the
um maths hubs are so important and this
new mpq are going to roll out is so
important because if if the teachers are
confident then it makes a big difference
on the kids and then part of making the
teachers confident and making the kids
engage is having the curriculum that is
engaging and as I said and Jillian did
brilliantly in her opening remarks it's
all the things where you are doing maths
but you don't quite realize you're doing
maths and it's making our curriculum
reflective of that and I said like you
know much more fun to learn about how a
free kick than it is probably to do time
and distance equations or angles right
and it's things like that which
increasingly we are putting into the
curriculum that I think you can see
children responding to really well and
then it's about us having a conversation
as a country right about us just
changing how we approach this so it
isn't okay to say well I don't do math
and everyone laughs right that doesn't
happen overnight and I think all of us
are probably for being honest with
ourselves all of us have been in a
conversation where that has happened
and it is okay but as I said not a
single person here would kind of proudly
Proclaim well I can't read or I don't do
reading that's not me right and we just
be honest ourselves about that now you
know that's for on all of us to slightly
change this into the cell when I saw the
reaction to this announcement when we
made it in January I could see that
right and I said we and I think the last
thing I'd say is it's making people
realize it's not an either or and I
don't mentioned this point before but
it's so important there is this idea
that we're kind of we should do more of
this and therefore less of that no this
needs to be additional it's
complementary we can do both things
together and if we get this right I tell
you if we get this right right we will
do something really special for our
young people right it will be setting
them up for Success not just in their
careers whatever they want to do
whatever you want to do whether it's
going to make the next Harry Potter or
whatever right but also just going about
your day-to-day lives making sure that
you can live a fulfilling life all those
big Financial things that impact your
day-to-day life right think about cost
of living how important it is right now
to understand what discounts are
available how do you make sure that your
credit cards are being managed properly
what's the right mortgage deal to go for
all these things so important for
day-to-day life and right now there's
probably too many people who don't have
the numeracy they need to make those
decisions that will support them and
their families but if we get this right
they will be able to and I think that
something that we can all look forward
to and celebrate perfect thank you so
much for having me it's been great to be
with you thank you